just after sunset we watched the biggest
movement of israeli armor we've seen so
far here
on the fringes of northern gaza as the
tanks moved south
heavy artillery stationed behind them
fired round after round of long-range
shells
a prolonged intensive barrage lasting
over an
hour well on the day that the israeli
military confirmed that it was
preparing a plan for a ground offensive
this is the kind of
heavy armory movement that we haven't
seen up until this point also
consistent heavy artillery fire as well
that plan is due to go up the chain of
command to the political leadership
for a decision to be made with darkness
another line of tanks
and further shelling perhaps the
preliminary phase of a ground attack
perhaps a ploy to pressure hamas
whichever the impact on northern gaza
was immediate
and heavy the first day of the eid
holiday
had started grimly enough for these
families it ended on the streets
exposed in fear of an israeli incursion
even as the fighting faction said
they would welcome one
nothing that the enemy is doing will
change our strategy we'll have a bigger
chance of killing and capturing more of
your soldiers
don't threaten us with what will bring
us victory this would be the shortest
way to our victory
earlier the israeli military had said it
carried out a series of major strikes
against hamas
destroying an intelligence unit in
southern rafah
knocking a hamas attack drone out of the
sky
for yet another day the rocket fire out
of gaza came in waves
again central and southern israel were
targeted by major barrages
and hamas said a new long-range rocket
was used to target the far
southern airport of ramon where israel
had re-routed incoming airliners
the israeli prime minister visiting iron
dome interceptor units
said the military attacks would continue
we continue to strike hamas while
defending our citizens
it will take more time a short time
later
he was on israel's second front a
parallel crisis
of lawless racial violence which has
gripped its towns and cities
the intelligence we have says that it is
very possible that there will be an
increase in violence here in the coming
days
there may be an exchange of blows here
and in cases like these
in order to suppress a riot we need to
use force
a lot of force we will use it while
giving full support to the israeli
police
in the town of batyam eid morning was
spent surveying the damage
of the attack the night before
they did it because we speak arabic we
are not bad people we did nothing we
never hurt anyone
we've been here for 20 years alongside
them as neighbors
family and friends we did not expect
this to happen
the intelligence about further violence
was soon proven accurate
israeli law enforcement so far unable to
stem this communal bloodletting
in laud a palestinian israeli firing on
jews
elsewhere jewish israeli journalists
attacked by jewish extremists
unhappy with their coverage this is a
spasm of internal insecurity
that like the military situation in the
south is at the moment
only escalating harry fawcett al jazeera
southern israel